[Music]
that was the spanish call via fox
deportes that was great daniel jones
trip and fall over the 15-yard line hit
a top speed of 21.23 miles per hour on
that run the fastest of any quarterback
at that point of the season longest run
by a quarterback since marcus mariota
went 87 yards and did not trip over any
of the yard lines on the way to the end
zone in 2015. they did score a touchdown
four plays later but uh
one of the most memorable moments of
daniel jones career even though he'd
like to forget it it brings him in and
i'm sure that was one of the factors to
put him at number 26 on the chris sims
top 40 countdown
there are the next few that we're going
to to discuss today they've been
revealed i think you're you're way ahead
of me on i am unbuttoned because we've
fallen behind
but for our purposes and we will catch
up we're daniel jones 26 and then a
couple of saints after that but let's
talk daniel jones yeah because here's my
question yeah where is he going to be
next year next year he's either going to
be in the top 20 or he isn't going to be
the starting quarterback of the job i
think that's right you're right this is
this is the year there's no excuses he's
got all the physical tools and
everything you need to be successful as
an nfl quarterback it's just time to put
it all together i mean that's really
what it is they they seem now to have at
least a team around him to certainly
give him a fighting chance that way hey
it's another year in the jason garrett
system so hopefully that's come together
and can mean better play for daniel
jones and the giants offense and
everything like that but when you break
down daniel jones there's a lot to like
there really is i mean controls the
football throws perfect spirals
everywhere got a real good arm it's not
a great arm it's not a superstar arm but
it's a good arm to where there's no
limitations to anything you have to do
with your offense or him making throws
you saw his ability to run he's a real
athlete he is i mean he's the type of
guy that can keep the ball on read
options and rip off 30 and 40 yard runs
but
now we got to learn how to play the game
better and mike you heard me say this
last year it's really the same problems
with daniel jones he did not grow much
in the department of what i would call
pocket awareness right we talked about
the strip fumbles you know from two
years ago that was an issue it's still
an issue as you can see here from the
stats and the interceptions have to say
are the same thing too it's too much of
holding the pocket let me hold the
pocket coach told me to go to one to two
to three to four okay i'm gonna stand
here and keep going through the reeds
and oh no the pocket's collapsing oh i
just got to throw it here oh
interception or oh the pocket's
collapsing and i'm still looking
downfield and somebody swats the ball
out of my hand he's got to get better
awareness than that there's got to be a
better backyard element to his game
that's what we got to see him really
improve on taking care of the football
in that department and i have no doubt
that he could do the other stuff to be a
good quarterback and make that offense
good
and you know chris sometimes it's as
simple as you can sit the guy down in a
meeting room you can take him to the
film room you can put him on the
practice field and you can hammer those
things into his brain over and over and
over again but
when it's time to go out
it all changes right right right it all
changes and you revert back to the
things you've always known the clock in
your head has not changed because and
people get confused by this look you are
at the center of one hell of a hurricane
when you're the quarterback of an nfl
team you got a lot of things that you
need to remember and when it's time to
remember them you're not going to
remember them you're just going to do
what you know yes and unfortunately for
daniel jones what he knows is holding
onto the ball too damn that's right
that's right and that's where he's got
to make an adjustment he he's too smart
he's too good of an athlete to stand
there like the statue of liberty in the
middle of these mosh pits too much and
you know i talk about this a little bit
on my podcast but hey the nfl's changed
i really do think he's trying to do good
and do what the coaches say
and be that pocket machine quarterback
and dice you up that way and hey that's
great i do admire his toughness he's
fearless in the pocket but it's you know
like the gift and the curse type thing
there it's yeah it's a gift at times but
it's a curse too and in the 2021 nfl
like it's changed now it's no longer you
know 1988 or 1997 where you just stand
in there and you look down the field and
you try to throw a ball into a tight
window like you have to have pocket
awareness as far as you got to look at
the pass rush a little bit you got to
there's too many crazy defenses there's
too many talented pass rushers to where
you can't just totally disregard the
people that are coming after you and
look downfield and just think okay i'll
be good
rogers mahomes even brady
if you watch games of them they drop
back to pass and okay they're looking
down field and now they pat the ball and
they assess around them they look around
wait is somebody there okay i'm gonna
pat it again eyes down field okay let me
make sure somebody around me just so i
don't get stripped sack or get hit as
i'm throwing the ball that's part of the
game now it's no longer like those old
coaching points of like don't look at
the pass rush no you have to look at the
pass rush now it's part of it because
the quarterback is expected to make
off-schedule plays when people aren't
there and things like that and that's to
me where he's really got to grow as a
player
no excuses for jones this year they
picked up kenny galaday in free agency
drafted cadarius tony in round one after
trading down right and added kyle
rudolph at tight end they have
everything room they have barclays back
barkley is healthy yeah this is it this
is it up or out
for daniel jones this year because
they're gonna have options available
that's right next year that's right
russell wilson aaron rodgers who knows
every year there's going to be a
revolving door of veteran quarterbacks
available if a team wants a quicker
upgrade than to roll the dice on a draft
pick and agree he'll be in position to
have a top 10 draft pick if they stink
this year because of daniel jones so
we'll see how that goes next two guys
from the same team jameis winston 25
taysom hill 24. threshold question does
that ranking
carry with it the implication that you
think hill should be the starter in new
orleans yes it does it does it does uh i
do believe he should be the starter now
i think it's really close i know we've
had this conversation and there's a lot
to like about jameis winston's game
there's no doubt i mean you and i have
both
talked in in high praise about his good
play he can do some really special
things i mean he's got a really good arm
he's a way better athlete than people
realize you know he sees the field well
it's the old thing we've talked about
mike he just doesn't have that governor
at times so where it's just like wait
the play is over throw it away the play
is over just go down you got sacked we
don't have to throw a ball and try to
shuffle it 15 yards in front of our face
into quadruple coverage you know that's
why i can't put him higher than that his
talent is greater than 25 certainly but
yes there's trust issues that i want to
believe that sean payton has coached out
of him and will make him better but i
haven't seen that yet i don't know that
yet so yeah there's a lot of starting
caliber superstar principles about
jameis winston's game there's no doubt
but there's two issues that keep him
where he's at right now one is that
decision making like we talked about it
can't be the last play of the game all
the time and then you know two would be
a little bit he's got to be control the
football a little bit better those 30
interceptions yeah some were dumb
decisions but he misses too many throws
too with that wind-up like kind of
motion he has where he swings the ball
where it's a little aaron at times if he
can fix those two things he could be a
starting quarterback and a superstar in
this league for a long long time
i wonder
how willing sean payton will be
to stick with whoever he picks as his
week one starter is he going to be
tempted
you know after a bad game yeah after a
bad decision after a bad throw
to yank
jameis winston for taysom hill or vice
versa
um
or or is he gonna want to give whoever
the starter is the full chance barring
injury to take the full season and show
what he can be that's going to be a heck
of a dilemma for him because he hasn't
had to deal with that as a head coach
because it's always been drew brees
right right yeah you knew you're like oh
well okay drew had a bad game or two
he's going to work out of this funk and
he's gonna get better yeah you don't
know that with this crew here we don't
you know and i would think that sean
coming from you know understanding
quarterbacks not easy him being the next
quarterback coming from the school
parcells that he's gonna give whoever he
names his week one starter at least
their time to kind of get their feet
planted in the ground and used to
playing before he starts to go okay now
it's it's been five weeks and it's been
really underwhelming and some bad reads
and some mistakes and this offense does
not look like what i expected then i
could see that then like okay four or
five games of bad then he starts to
think about that but you know with
taysom hill
i got him ranked one spot in front of
jameis winston
i know yeah if you think about
quarterback from the traditional sense
yeah he's not as good as jameis winston
but it's still better than you think and
when you talk about tayden's taste some
wins i mean taysom hill
you got to evaluate him as like a force
of nature it's about what is he's a
weapon at the quarterback position it's
what he does to defenses because of his
skill set and the pressure he puts on
you that way let alone
we saw him go three and one last year
and be a really good thrower of the
football and have very good control
throwing higher degree difficulty type
throws than maybe even drew brees was
throwing in the offense last year it was
a lot more down the field it was back
shoulders you know he found a connection
with michael thomas so i think between
the athlete i've seen
and the preseason from two years ago and
then going three what three and one this
year
i just look at it and go it's gone
better and better every year and that's
where i look at taysom hill as yeah he's
a quarterback but he's also kind of a
force of nature and what he brings to
the field as an athlete and what he's
going to do to defenses and putting
pressure on them
you know if i didn't know better i would
have thought you almost said tamus i
almost said taysom winston i almost said
taylor jason winston
hill
tamus winston there's all sorts of
permutations there if there's a tie yeah
baseball tie goes to the runner football
does the tie literally go to the runner
and take some help i think it does go to
jameis winston i think it does i mean
you you tell me let's talk this out like
i mean taysom hill's his pet project
toy baby that we've talked about for the
last three years right and he did go
three and one and has been there i would
think if it's a tie
that taysom will get the benefit of the
doubt uh at least that would be my
thought what about you yeah but but you
could make jameis the quarterback and
have tasem on the field if it's all
about your rights
that's right that's right that's
interesting i know you're right
uh it's gonna be i i just have the this
sense
of the liking of taysom hill i think you
and i have both got the sense that sean
payton's intrigued by this new aged
attack and offense he might be able to
run with taysom hill and
i think when you just you know again
break down his quarterback play i
understand the drop back pass game not
beat might not be to drew brees's level
but i think he'd still he's gonna be
able to watch film from last year
whatever and goes we were still good
dropping back to throw with this guy and
he could do some things that are gonna
scare the hell out of defenses with his
ability to launch the ball down the
field and make power throws let's not
forget the last few years when they
wanted to make power throws they brought
taysom hill in the game some way to push
the ball down the field instead of drew
brees and i think that's an element you
could see in their offense more if he's
the quarterback
and one important factor we've discussed
in the past which guy
that sean payton believes will be able
to digest process sure and implement and
execute
five seven ten new plays that peyton
shows up with on the morning of game day
right that he spotted in his final film
review or looking at
a reel of all touchdowns that have been
scored in the month of october whatever
the case may be he's always looking for
ideas who can incorporate those the way
that drew brees could automatically and
not miss
good point and off they go that's going
to be huge now it's not necessarily
relevant for week one
when they play the packers and they have
seven months to get ready right but it
will be relevant right after that or
five and beyond that's right right after
that and you know even like to your
point there yeah psycho's like sean
payton they come up with ideas on
saturday night and you're like damn this
is six seven new plays like you're
talking about and digesting the offense
people like sean payton you know you get
into the you get into the facility on a
wednesday morning i know this because it
was like this with john gruden you might
have 80 new plays that week you know
some are like yes similar plays but it's
a different personnel set and a
different formation and you got to make
sure to tell wait this tight end who's
been doing this play has been running
this one route but now he's going to be
running a different route lined up
somewhere else and you're the
quarterback you got to be the one to
tell them let them know like hey this is
what you're doing you gotta be over here
oh everything like that here's your
rules blah blah blah and that's where
those offenses get tricky just the
amount of volume that's thrown on you
week after week after week to where
you're going whoa it's another 110 plays
another 100 place another 140 plays whoa
we got all these checks and that's got
to be part of the thought process
certainly in deciding this for for sean
payton i would think
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports